okay this is a very disturbing story and
I I wish we didn't have yet another one
of these examples but Wisconsin
billionaire Samuel Curtis Johnson the
third of SC Johnson fame pled guilty to
sexual assault of his stepdaughter
dating back to when she was as young as
twelve years old but he has been
sentenced only 24 months in jail now he
was originally charged with felony
sexual assault of a child he allegedly
repeatedly targeted his stepdaughter for
three years starting when she was as
young as twelve years old his
stepdaughter initially told police that
Johnson was a sex addict and touched her
inappropriately 15 to 20 times she told
her mom about the abuse in order to
protect her uh younger sister and
Johnson confessed when the mother
confronted him the felony charge could
have carried up to 40 years in prison
but the prosecutor had to downgrade the
charges to a mere misdemeanor because
both the girl and her mother wouldn't
cooperate and the entire case started to
fall apart at that time and thus we end
up with just four months in jail as
opposed to potentially up to 40 years in
prison now this does relate to some
specifics in the legal system when you
don't have cooperation from the
individuals that are involved as victims
or as as potential witnesses you have a
real problem with getting the same
charges past so I totally get that right
based on what ultimately he pled guilty
to there was not a basis for 40 years in
prison but there are so many people who
don't seem to get Louis the stigma the
hostility of imagine you're a victim of
sexual assault and you know that there
is huge stigma associated with it on top
of it there's the power dynamics that
this is your stepfather on top of that
there's the dynamics that this is a
billionaire heir to the SC Johnson of
fortune who is well-known in the
community is very well-equipped legally
and then on top of that consider that
this is a kid and we we sort of have to
understand that yeah
according to the letter of the law
indeed you can't send in someone to 40
years in prison for the misdemeanor that
they ultimately pled to but we should
really be looking at the entire system
because big picture this is yet another
rich person who was able to take
advantage of the justice system that
exists for rich people in this country
and end up with four months in jail for
what we believe to be 15 to 20 instances
of sexual assault on a girl that was 12
years old yeah this story is it is an
example of just about every problem we
have yeah I'm with this type of thing in
this country not just this country
really everywhere I in many countries uh
because well people are just afraid to
speak out and I can understand that
you're facing a billionaire who you are
related to word I mean it just seems you
know many times and sadly armed people
think it's better and easier to just
avoid confrontation and avoid all of
these problems yeah then actually
addressing the issue I think that's just
a human thing and we had a bunch of
other examples of this Rachel we had the
wealthy air who raped this
three-year-old daughter was recently
sentenced to probation because the judge
felt that the wealthy guy wouldn't do
well in prison we had that wealthy
teenager who successfully at least
initially avoided jail time for killing
four people drunk driving because he had
what is being colloquy described as
affluenza his rich parents were so rich
that they never taught him that is con
his actions have consequences and we've
we have a number of examples of this
yeah and I think this is also kind of
reminding me of the case in the recent
case in San Francisco with that young
man who sexually assaulted that girl and
is kind of getting off easier and I'm
yeah starting to think if they can kind
of implement some sort of larger
punishment will that ever kind of maybe
be a better deterrent than what's going
on now because people are seeing time
and time again that they can get away
with these types of crimes with a small
punishment so what's what's their
incentive to not do it yeah creates a
feedback loop where people in positions
of power and privilege positions see
that other people in their position are
doing these things and one way or
another they don't end up really being
punished and I forget the the the the
all-american Stanford dude is who
Rachel's referring to I feel like his
name was like Brock Witherington
I don't remember exactly Brock Turner
that's what it was exactly yet there is
a feedback loop effect here isn't there
there is uh affluenza I guess we can
call it as part of affluenza uh
condition gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low use
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
tdps the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30 day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s